[Música]
cuando tenía cuatro años yo me
encontraba de viaje en un parque de
diversiones me acuerdo que estaba muy
emocionado porque iba a ver a uno de mis
personajes favoritos al entrar a la
atracción de hiper le pedí permiso me
sopas me senté en la parte de adelante
en donde se encontraban todos los niños
al estar yo y sentado pude notar que
muchas personas se estaban riendo yo la
verdad no podía entender nada
tanta era mi frustración de no poder
entender nada que no es broma hasta
comencé a llorar
y cuando termine volví con mis papás y
les dije mamá papá porque no entiendo
nada porque no me puedo reír como lo
están haciendo los demás a lo que ellos
me respondieron hijo este en otro idioma
está en inglés yo no me di cuenta de la
importancia de ese momento y la manera
en que iba a cambiar mi vida las
palabras se me quedaron a lo largo del
día s esté en otro idioma está en inglés
me acuerdo que estaba comiendo un
algodón de azúcar cuando le dije a mis
papás mamá papá quiero aprender inglés
fue gracias a esta declaración porque
así se los dije que mi vida cambió mi
vida cambió completamente porque fue el
día en que nació mi deseo por aprender
y les garantizo que fue todo un reto
para mis padres y lograr que aprendiera
inglés sólo tenía 4 años no sabía ni
leer ni escribir buscar una manera y un
lugar en donde lo hiciera y va a estar
difícil pero como todo el niño de 4 años
yo estaba insiste e insiste diciéndole a
mis papás que tenía que hacerlo para que
cuando volviéramos me pudiera reír con
los demás niños conforme pasó el tiempo
buscamos un lugar y empecé a conocer el
inglés descubrí las maneras en cómo
aprender otro idioma podían ser
divertidas yo en ningún momento sentí
una obligación al ir a estudiarlo porque
tenía que aprenderlo para la escuela yo
solo lo hacía porque quería reírme
quería disfrutarlo
y me puse a pensar y el aprender llega a
nosotros mucho antes y sin que nos
diéramos cuenta desde pequeños
aprendemos a caminar comer hablar
charles chaplin nos lo dice la vida es
como una obra de teatro sin ensayos por
eso hay que cantar reír llorar vivir
intensamente cada momento de tu vida
antes de que baje el telón y te
preguntes bueno que he hecho en mi vida
en este caso que he aprendido en mi vida
muchos filósofos debaten si llegamos al
mundo como una hoja en blanco no hayamos
llegado como hayamos llegado algo que sí
sé es que le fuimos añadiendo nuevas
cosas a esta hoja de papel cosas que van
enriqueciendo nuestras vidas así fue
pasando la mía y añadiendo nuevas cosas
a mi hoja de papel una de las cosas que
desgraciadamente llevo a mi hoja y se me
quedó grabado fue un número 3.8 este
número equivale a los libros que lee en
promedio mexicano al año y reconocía los
libros los descubrí porque me causaban
curiosidad a que el niño no le gustan
las historias de piratas y superhéroes
en busca de aventuras pero hubo un
momento en el que me di cuenta que
mientras leía por diversión al mismo
tiempo estaba aprendiendo ahora cada vez
que entre una biblioteca me digo a mí
mismo cuántas cosas me quedan por
aprender
con palabras de nuestro querido amigo
sócrates el filósofo yo sólo sé que no
sé nada
ese pensamiento fue el que me impulsó a
plantearme una meta el ayer me 52 libros
al año
si para los que tengan la duda el año
tiene 52 semanas
recuerdo que se lo dije una amiga y lo
primero que me dijo fue que de dónde iba
a sacar el dinero para comprar 52 libros
por suerte yo tengo una biblioteca en la
escuela y eso me ayudó a no gastar tanto
dinero
bueno al final la verdad no le di 52
libras 654
y es que muchos amigos me decían que si
no me pasaba todo el tiempo leyendo la
verdad se invertir bastante tiempo y al
final bastante dinero
pero aprendí muchas cosas que no conocía
aprendí que el budismo nació del
hinduismo conocía la cultura japonesa en
los años 80 descubrí porque bob dylan el
cantante con el premio nobel de
literatura y porque es uno con muchos
escritores logré componer un examen tro
de act y lico también entendí porque él
es igual a mc al cuadrado la famosa
ecuación de albert einstein o porque
tenía la diosa de la sabiduría es fan
número uno de un simple mortal llamado
listas y entre muchas otras
fue así como los libros se volvieron mis
compañeros en esta aventura de aprender
nuevas cosas y muchas personas me dicen
andrés por que estudiase eso si ni
siquiera lo estamos viendo en la escuela
y puede ser que muchas de las cosas que
aprenda no las vaya a ver en la escuela
pero ese no es el objetivo para mí el
objetivo es irme creando intriga y
curiosidad de conocer algo nuevo estoy
seguro de que podemos eliminar ese matiz
que muchas personas tenemos en la cual
nos enfocamos ya sea en un área en lo
que estamos trabajando o en lo que vamos
a estudiar y tienen razón si debemos
enfocarnos en algo para volvernos buenos
pero la cosa no se debe quedar ahí
mientras más cosas sepamos más posibles
futuros los estamos creando
y hoy en día vivimos en pleno siglo 21 y
existe algo que nos ayuda a la aventura
de aprender nuevas cosas a este algo lo
llamamos el internet el internet también
fue uno de mis compañeros que volvieron
el aprender mi forma de vida por ejemplo
los famosos tutoriales eso es que muchas
personas ven y yo he incluido a los
famosos cursos mucho los cursos en links
masivos en los que podemos aprender gran
variedad de temas y sin costo alguno a
los millones de películas que tenemos en
el celular gracias a servicios que nos
permiten pagar una vez al mes y tener un
catálogo masivo todas estas cosas hacen
que la aprender entra en nuestras vidas
y nos vienen de una manera divertida de
una manera interesante
porque hubo un momento en mi vida en el
que me hice las preguntas bueno he
aprendido qué cosas he descubierto sólo
por diversión cuantas me faltan por
descubrir en la mitología griega existe
un dios llamado cronos es el más temible
del panteón griego es el dios del tiempo
porque va pasando nuestras vidas y
dejamos muchas cosas que pudiésemos
haber aprendido dejamos nuestra hoja de
papel a ya sentada
o como diría garcía márquez en macondo
los pergaminos están escritos desde
siempre y para siempre
y las estirpes condenadas a cien años de
soledad
no tienen una segunda oportunidad sobre
la faz de la tierra
entonces hay que agarrar esa oportunidad
y aventarnos aventarnos como 'alicia en
el país de las maravillas' o los tres
mosqueteros con sus aventuras y volver
el aprender nuestra forma de vida así sí
cronos me preguntaste yo le pudiera
responder
tronos no permite que nada ni nadie
matar a mi curiosidad aprendí descubrí
investigue pero lo más importante de
todo esto es que crecí
en la india existe un edificio de 73
metros se llama el taj mahal es una obra
magnífica creada gracias a un solo
sentimiento ese que hace mover a todo el
mundo el amor logremos que con ese amor
tal y como lo sentía el príncipe
jajajjaja tanto que le construyó el
mausoleo más importante de la historia a
su esposa así como el inmortal hizo su
amor así nosotros hay que inmortalizar
ese deseo por el aprender y construyamos
nuestro edificio lleno de futuros que
lleguen de aquí hasta el noveno cielo de
dante alighieri en su libro de la divina
comedia'
un escritor haruki murakami nos dice que
la capacidad de creer plenamente en otro
es uno de los valores más bellos del ser
humano
porque todos somos muy ignorantes pero
lo que ocurre es que no todos ignoramos
las mismas cosas
y si ahorita estuviera en el parque de
diversiones pero a los 16
y entraría la atracción
presentaría junto a los niños
se apagarían las luces
yo no podría dejar de pensar
que voy a llorar otra vez
pero esta vez hay un cambio
voy a llorar pero de felicidad
felicidad
porque por fin me voy a poder reír con
los demás niños
y cuando salga de la atracción yo les
garantizo
que la cosa apenas está por comenzar
muchas gracias